[Musique]
elle a été jadis au coeur de la création
érigé au centre du monde de l'univers de
l'esprit de dieu
[Musique]
pendant 500 ans elle a abrité une cour
uniquement préoccupé de pouvoir et de
privilèges
elle a été construite pour un homme le
fils de dieu mais c'était à la fois un
palais et une prison et que ce soit au
meilleur comme au pire instant il était
difficile de faire la différence
c'était enfin le siège d'une dynastie
qui devait durer à jamais mais qui
s'éteignent et progressivement au cours
des ans
[Musique]
c'est
la cité interdite
[Musique]
au cours de l'année ses 188 un
fonctionnaire du gouvernement venus de
la province d'anhui arrive à béziers il
s'appelle jiangsu lyon
quoi
et le parcouru 1600 km un long voyage de
30 jours il fait les derniers kilomètres
tout seul sans ses serviteurs ils sont
moyens de transport
car derrière la porte il y à la grande
cité intérieur la cité interdite
[Musique]
nous savons ce qui s'est passé au cours
de l'audience de yang
car tout ce qui arrive derrière ces
portes et scrupuleusement noté est
conservé que ce soit les oraisons
funèbres les menus des dîners les
déclarations de guerre tout est là dans
les 50 millions de manuscrits qui
constituent des archives impérial se
soucie de détail est l'une des
caractéristiques de la cité interdite
l' harmonie avec l'univers en est une
autre
lorsque cette harmonie est rompu cela
signifie que la dynastie risque de
s'effondrer dans sa jeunesse
yang a assisté à la chute de la dynastie
ming vieille de 300 ans et qui a
succombé à une éclipse solaire
sa mission actuelle consiste à rendre
compte des derniers mauvais présage
que ce soit des typhons large des côtes
de canton ou une comète aperçu au dessus
du désert de gobi
ces signes trahissent la lassitude des
cieux et annonce un chaos susceptibles
de mettre fin au règne de l'empereur
quand la cité interdite surgit de la
grande plaine de chine du nord au début
du xvème siècle c'est le plus grand
ensemble de palets jamais vu ça l'est
encore aujourd'hui elle a été bâtie pour
refléter la gloire éternelle des
empereurs ming cent mille hommes et ont
travaillé et la nuit leur four éclairer
les plaines alentours 100 millions de
briques 200 millions de tuiles furent
nécessaires à la construction ainsi que
du bois d'oeuvre venus du sud du yunnan
il fallu quatre ans pour acheminer les
arbres par les rivières et le grand
canal quand tout fut terminée les
ouvriers disparurent laissons la cité un
empereur et à la cour qui le servent et
fermés au monde
elle prétend contenir tout le cosmos en
ses murs c'est un univers dans l'univers
est situé au centre de cet univers très
surveillé le trône impérial
tout le pouvoir par de cette pièce
entourée de 9999 autre pièce d'après la
légende
les jaunes sont consacrés au pouvoir les
rouges au bonheur et partout on retrouve
les dragons impériaux destinée à porter
la pluie et la prospérité à la terre
c'est dragon été sculptée dans une pièce
de marbre si vaste qu'il fallut la
transporter en hiver sur une route
couverte de glace quand on s'aperçut que
le marbre était trop lourd la légende
raconte que les soldats de l'empereur
dur le fouetter jusqu'à ce qu'ils se
mettent en mouvement
l' empire est divisé en 18 provinces et
des rapports des renseignements des
livres de contes arrive tous les jours
dans la cité interdite
[Musique]
cet empire qui compte 150 millions
d'âmes d'origine chinoise mongols ou man
show et gouverner à partir de ce lieu
par l'organisation bureaucratique la
plus ancienne et la plus sophistiquée du
monde
un fonctionnaire peut traverser tout
lempire mais il ne peut pas franchir ce
mur derrière lequel se tient le palais
impérial à par l'empereur les seules
personnes autorisées à y pénétrer sont
ses concubines et ccnucc au sein de la
cité les eunuques que constituent la
population la plus nombreuse
il y en eu jusqu'à 3000 qui gravitaient
autour du fils du ciel comme des
satellites
bien qu'ils les considèrent comme des
esclaves
l'empereur ne peut vivre sans eux tous
les matins il habille l'empereur il
l'est de revêtir l'une des 1000 tunique
qu'ils possèdent chacune est destiné aux
différentes saisons et la plupart sont
jaunes impériale l'empereur se souvient
quand je pense à mon enfance ma tête
s'emplit d'une brume jaune ma chaise à
porteurs étaient jaunes mes vêtements
étaient jaunes les bols dans lesquels je
mangeais était jaune
tout était jaune cela m'a fait penser
dès mon plus jeune âge que j'étais de
nature divine l'empereur kangxi est
monté sur le trône en 16 161 il devait
régner pendant 61 en bas âge d'or de la
chine impériale
le mandat de kangxi comme celui de tous
les empereurs ne lui est pas conféré par
le peuple mais par les cieux chaque
année au lever du soleil le jour du
solstice d'hiver
ce mandat est renouvelé ce jour là
l'empereur et sa suite quitte la cité
interdite et se rendent au temple du
ciel situé de l'autre côté de la ville
pour y faire un sacrifice et des voeux
les rues de beijing qui ont été
nettoyées sont vides
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
jean
[Musique]
un philosophe chinois a écrit un jour si
le souverain est juste alors les
énergies créatrices sont harmonieuses et
conciliante
les vents et la pluie arriveront au bon
moment et les étoiles favorable
apparaîtront
et alors le dragon jaune descendra les
cieux
[Musique]
l'empereur est au centre de l'univers
son autorité qui lui vient du ciel
signifie que quand mme shi comme tous
les empereurs détient le pouvoir absolu
[Musique]
dans son journal il écrit l'anper
détient tous les pouvoirs dont celui de
vie et de mort sur ses sujets il sait
que parfois ces gens doivent être
ramenés dans le droit chemin par une
exécution
bien qu'une audience à la cour suffisent
souvent à calmer leur arrogance le ko
tao signifie littéralement se cogner la
tête canci adoré voir ses généraux
s'humilier de cette façon mais
l'empereur c'est que l'intimidation a
des limites des hommes qui ont peur
risque de garder pour eux des
renseignements importants et cela peut
être des instrus kanshi ordonné ces deux
vins de ne jamais déformer la vérité
celui-ci christine kissinger aulas
l'astronomie est une obsession chez
l'empereur il s'y intéresse depuis l'âge
de 8 ans son maître et le meilleur de
toute la chine
bien qu'il ne soit pas chinois le
jésuite ferdinand verbier est est
occidental est donc un barbare mais
c'est aussi un astronome brillant et par
conséquent d'une grande valeur pour la
cour impériale en plus de deux siècles
peu d'occidentaux se sont aventurés
aussi loin
la chine de son arrivée à baiji non
c'est 160 verbier ce qui vient de rome
apporte avec lui les connaissances de
kepler et de galilée
l'empereur le nomme au comité des
astronomes eelv a révolutionné
l'astronomie chinoise ont fait
construire un nouvel observatoire et
l'occidental commencé à étudier les
étoiles pour le fils du ciel son site
web
[Musique]
à tonga sortir la lame à à aziz al aziza
en faisant de verbier est un dignitaire
l'empereur a rompu avec la coutume
chinoise la curiosité intellectuelle de
kangxi autorisé une lumière venant de
l'extérieur à pénétrer dans la cité
interdite et l'empereur est un élève
passionnés un soir l'empereur me fit
asseoir près de lui et me demanda de lui
nommé toutes les constellations qui
apparaissait
[Musique]
il nomma tout d'abord celle qu'il
connaissait heureux de me montrer son
érudition l'astronomie et est une
science mais aussi à cette époque un
moyen de se protéger
un nouveau calendrier dévoilé tous les
ans à la porte du méridien depuis des
années les astronomes de la cour ont
fait de mauvaises prévisions leurs
erreurs ont conduit le pays à la famine
on a planté les graines trop tôt ou bien
on fait les récoltes trop tard
le prestige et l'autorité de kangxi sont
fondés sur la méthode scientifique les
calendriers de kangxi étaient fiables
ils aidèrent à renforcer sa dynastie
mais l'aide apportée par ceux venus de
l'ouest n'est pas toujours bien vu dans
la cité interdite
[Musique]
si l'empereur a élevé un étranger le
jésuite vers bies d'oran de dignitaires
c'est peut-être parce qu'il se sent
lui-même un étranger un match haut en 16
144 sa famille venue de l'autre côté de
la grande muraille est arrivé à la tête
d'une armée de maraudeur en quelques
jours la dynastie ming anciennes et
affaibli est tombé devant les hommes
venus du nord
les mandchous sont de très bons
cavaliers il excelle à l'arc
mais ce ne sont pas des intellectuels ce
sont des fous à 10,2 un fonctionnaire
sans élégance et sans caractère canci
l'empereur manchu de la nouvelle
dynastie ching veut que cela change
il se plonge dans l'histoire de la chine
ancienne ils préfèrent être érudit
plutôt que soldat
[Applaudissements]
malgré tout il ne peut se passer de
l'armée en effet de nombreux chinois
n'acceptent pas leur nouveau maître et
pendant les premières années du règne de
kangxi les révoltes sont une menace
constante
il faudra attendre 19 ans avant que les
mandchous se sentent en sécurité dans la
cité interdite
[Musique]
et le nouvel ordre s'installa
le pouvoir des eunuques est l'un des
problèmes les plus importants auxquels
l'empereur doit faire face au cours de
la dynastie ming les ont pris goût à la
politique et rien ne semble pouvoir se
faire sans les soudoyer
comme si les remet à leur place celle de
serviteurs
on
depuis toujours les eunuques ont été des
volontaires ils pouvaient changer d'avis
jusqu'aux moments de la castration comme
chez a dit d'eux qu'ils babinet comme
des bébés mais ils garantissent la
chasteté des femmes du palais le roi de
la manière
un barnum chindaï option
[Musique]
et
l'empereur kangxi à une piètre opinion
de ses menus qu ils sont très
différentes et gens ordinaires ils sont
comparables à de misérables insectes je
leur assigne les tâches les plus basses
junior aussi bien leur mouvement
d'humeur que leurs sourires et je
m'assure qu'ils vivent dans la pauvreté
si je leur accorde ton de grâce ils
deviennent arrogants écarté de la
politique
les en portage de repas c'est les
vêtements de soie de l'empereur et de
chasser les rongeurs
ils chassent aussi les mouches qui se
posent sur les fruits secs et de leurs
voix de fausset et chanté dans les
opéras de la cour
on est loin de la position qu'ils
espéraient occuper c'est moi qui ai
choisi de me faire castrer c'était un
tout petit sacrifice comparé à ce que
j'en attendais mes parents étaient
pauvres et par cette transformation
j'étais assuré d'une vie facile entouré
par la beauté la magnificence
j'étais aussi assuré de partager
l'intimité de femme ravissante qu'ils
noueraient envers moi aucune crainte
si je savais me prendre je pourrais
devenir plus riche et plus puissant que
certains hauts dignitaires de lempire
sommes nous heureux comment pouvez vous
l'imaginer nous n'avons pas des pousses
pas de fils pour assurer notre
descendance et pour venir faire des
sacrifices sur notre tombe
nous n'osons pas réclamé le bonheur
cependant certains d'entre eux se sont
sans doute trouvé mêlé aux intrigues de
la cour
sinon le décret suivant n'aurait pas été
nécessaire
à partir de maintenant quiconque tentera
de se mêler des affaires du gouvernement
de s'approprier quelques pouvoirs en
acceptant des pots-de-vin sera
immédiatement mise à mort et aura la
tête coupée
[Musique]
les concubines impérial sont elles aussi
captive au sein de la cité interdite
certaines d'entre elles ne verront
l'empereur qu'une seule fois au cours de
leur vie malgré tout à la mort de
l'empereur elles seront obligées de se
retirer dans des pavillons qui entoure
le jardin des favorites oublié où elles
vivront jusqu'à la fin de leurs jours
le nombre des concubines que l'empereur
peut prendre est il limité de ses
devoirs et de donner l empire un autre
fils du ciel
ce qui justifie les normes arendt et les
prédécesseurs de kangxi entretenait ce
dernier juge que c'est excessif
elle a réduit le nombre des concubines à
moins de cent celles qui portent le fils
de l'empereur vont pouvoir éviter les
besoins du festi dieuze mais pas l'ennui
les eunuques au service d'une concubine
bénéficient de privilèges si celle ci
est choisi l'empereur fait toujours son
choix après le dîner canci dean toujours
seul on dresse devant lui une large
variété de plats à la plupart desquelles
ils ne touchent pas il y a là des
racines de lotus des crevettes à tête de
dragon des riz parfumé et des fruits
secs des nids d'hirondelles et des
pattes d'ours braisé ainsi que le plat
traditionnel le potage de poulet cuisiné
avec des champignons noirs
le moment est maintenant venu de choisir
une concubine dans la nuit chaque nuque
essai de guider son choix chaque morceau
de bois représente une concubine et les
eunuques les dispose avec soin pour
pousser l'empereur à choisir leurs
concubines
si l'empereur jette son dévolu sur leurs
maîtresses il en récolteront les
bénéfices mais vu le grand nombre de
concubine et les centaines de noeuds que
qui rivalisent pour attirer son
attention
tomczyk déjà éventé tout leur tour
comme çi à féconder 30 de ses concubines
elles lui ont donné au total 56 enfants
la maternité apporte immédiatement la
concubine d'un changement de statut elle
n'a plus à accomplir les tâches
ménagères
elle n'a plus qu'à se distraire c'est le
cas de celle qui veut s'occuper de
l'enfant comme y règne l'héritier
présomptif
non
cheval maman je la cherche pas
je vois là
maillard va sinon
le petit garçon a été souvent souffrent
au cours de son enfance et tout a été
fait pour qu'il vive pendant dix ans il
s'est battu contre la maladie
ensuite line renaud qui signifie le
bienheureux descendants a reçu une
éducation à l'ancienne dans la tradition
de confucius comme aux premiers temps de
l'époque ming lors en favori de
l'empereur et préparer pour le pouvoir
j'ai fait monde et les plus âgées rue
diderot line pour lui enseigner la
morale
il a étudié le livre d'histoire et
appris les principes de gouvernement
je nomme in rennes mon futur héritier
[Musique]
mais trente ans plus tard le père allait
avoir honte de son fils
[Musique]
le règne de kanshi qui promettait à ses
débuts à les connaître des difficultés
pendant soixante hiver kangxi fut
empereur de la cité interdite
son règne fut prospère mais toute joie
avait disparu maintenant
[Musique]
le 60e hiver de l'empereur elle et être
le plus noir de son règne
c'est son fils préféré in ring qui
suscitait ce désespoir
tout avait commencé par des rumeurs et
des intrigues de cour mais s'était
rapidement transformée en fait
indiscutable par la voix de réseaux
secrets
l'empereur avait découvert que son fils
était incapable de régner durant les
verts 10 722 un message spécial
s'étaient présentés aux portes de la
cité interdite le message qu'il
apportait contenait la pire des
nouvelles comme çi savait déjà que son
fils était tyrannique et cruel il savait
aussi qu'il avait acheté deux jeunes
garçons à seules fins de satisfaire son
plaisir sexuel qu'il avait détourné des
fonds de l'état et volé des tribus
destinée à son père
comment
nombre de courtisans craignait le fils
de l'empereur ce qui explique l
existence de réseaux d'information mais
cette dernière nouvelle glanées par ces
espions serait la plus douloureuse que
l'empereur vieillissant aurait jamais à
entendre
canci ignorant la tradition impériale
avait invité de désigner officiellement
un successeur le scandale naissant qui
concernait son fils préféré était
l'unique raison de ce retard ces
dernières années quand j avais appris à
craindre l'arrivée de ces petites boîtes
jaunes
cet hiver-là le message révéler
l'existence d'une rébellion fomentée par
son fils de trahison à l'intérieur du
palais et d'un projet de parricide son
héritier avait l'intention d'attenter à
ses jours
je ne trouvais jamais leur peau comme on
pouvait le laisser ligne rennes accéder
au trône impérial
lui qui était si excessif si exigeons si
important pendant plusieurs années j'ai
souffert en silence
je me soumettais mesan mauvaise nature
ne changeait pas mon coeur n'était plus
que cendres mes espoirs s'étaient
évanouis
qu'adviendrait-il de lempire que j'avais
hérité de mes ancêtres
un père que je n'avais presque jamais vu
mourut à l'âge de 23 ans et je n'avais
que huit ans quand on me coupe pas les
cheveux mabhija de blanc couleur du
deuil et que le corps de mon père
recouvert de neuf rideaux de soie jaune
imprimée d'un dragon fut conduit au
palais de la pureté sous le grondement
des cloches
voilà
tout homme qui a vécu doit mourir et
j'ai puisé mon esprit pour le bien de
l'enppi j'ai été vénéré par tout un
peuple et j'ai joué de tous les plaisirs
de ce monde il n'existe rien que je n'ai
eu le bonheur de goûter et maintenant
que j'ai atteint un âge avancé je n'ai
droit new report ni à la tranquillité
aussi je considère ce pays comme une
sandale usées et toutes les richesses du
monde n'ont pas plus de valeur à mes
yeux que la bourre et le sable si je
pouvais mourir sans être la cause de
nouveaux troubles
mon voeu le plus cher serait exaucé
l'empereur kangxi mourut le 20 décembre
10 722 lempire devait en être informée
et la succession au trône assuré comme
çi au cours de ces derniers jours
d'existence avait déshérités son fils de
la confusion qui ont suivi émergea
yuzhen son successeur
yuzhen pas porte à une certaine
stabilité à la dynastie et treize années
plus tard c'est son propre fils qui lui
succéda sous le nom de chin langues
l'éminence éternelle cette fois aucun
scandale ne vint entaché la succession
durant la première année de son règne
mon père avait inscrit mon nom et
l'avait placé dans un coffret scellé
dans la grande salle du palais quand il
nous quitte à pour son voyage éternelle
j'ouvris sow coffret en présence de ses
ministres et je découvris que j'étais
destiné au trône
[Musique]
tine longue fut un empereur dans la plus
pure tradition mandchoue c'était un
chasseur n'est qu'ils aimaient les défis
c'est durant son règne que l' empire
connu son apogée
l'empereur était toujours dépositaire du
monde à céleste mais il disposait
également d'une puissante armée
le royaume birman le royaume d'annam du
siam le tibet la corée toutes ces
nations verte à connaître la suprématie
chinoise
[Musique]
la vie que menait une longue durée cité
interdite et est sensiblement la même
que celle de kangxi sentant plus tôt
une vie recluse sans aucun contact avec
le monde extérieur met toujours un point
fixe et brillant dans le firmament
toujours le royaume parmi les royaux
cependant en europe
de nouvelles puissances voyait le jour
et avec elles des ambitions la mesure de
leur influence
aux yeux de l'occident la chine
apparaissait comme un empire gigantesque
mais obsolète
l' empire chinois n'est qu'un vieux
guerrier foo kune re succession
d'officiers parvenu à préserver et dont
seule l'apparence et la taille intimiste
encore ses voisins un jour s'est empirée
que la trempe petits morceaux
de l'intérieur de la cité interdite les
peuples vivant delà des frontières de la
chine apparaissaient comme des barbares
pendant deux siècles les barbares les
plus familiers de la cour impériale
furent les prêtres jésuites oms était
quelquefois méfier d'eux mais jamais on
ne les avait craint mais vers la fin de
son règne chine langue elle devoir faire
face à une autre race de barbares
c'était la compagnie des indes
orientales de la couronne britannique
pour les hommes qui la dirigeait la
chine représentait un immense marché
inexploité une source potentielle de
profits considérables que ce marché
demeure fermée au commerce occidentale
était un affront à l'orgueil et au
portefeuille des britanniques durant
l'été 1793 chine longue fut informé que
ces derniers étaient en route pour
beijing leur mission négocier avec
l'empereur un traité donne en libre
accès à la chine aux compagnies
anglaises
l'ambassadeur mandaté par le roi george
iii était lord mccartney bien que la
chaîne était habitué relations avec
l'étranger l'arrivée d'un émissaire venu
une nation ou si lointaine est aussi
exigeante fut un précédent pour
l'empereur quand on traite avec des
barbares la difficulté est de savoir ne
pas se montrer trop généreux outre
aurait dix ans lorsque l'ambassadeur de
grande bretagne se présentera il ne
faudra pas le traité comme s'il venait
du royaume de birmanie ou d'annam qui
eux nous verse un tribut chaque année
c'était la moindre des exigences de
mccartney et il fait également savoir
qu'il n'avait pas l'intention de faire
des courbettes deux empires fier et
arrogant devait trouver un moyen
d'entrer en contact sens aux français
mais également son perdre la face
pendant la première entrevue très brève
on trouvera donc un compromis macartney
offrit de s'agenouiller devant ching
longue comme il le faisait devant son
propre droit mais c'est tout le
protocole
ces querelles de protocoles n'augurait
rien de bon pour le rendez-vous de
beijing
je ne me souviens pas avoir reçu message
plus désagréable de toute ma vie je dû
me lever et me rater jusqu'à la cité
interdite
après trois heures d'attentes nous fûmes
conduit dans une cour où nous devions
rencontrer un chêne le grand callao de
l'empereur c'est à dire le premier
ministre est là nous découvrîmes le
trône impérial recouvert de soie jaune
sur lequel était posé un rouleau de
papier
comme convenu macartney ne fit pas de
courbettes à l'empereur il mais juste un
genou à terre et s'inclina devant un
trou ne vide et un rouleau de papier le
document contenait un refus hautain et
méprisant la vertu et la puissance de la
dynastie céleste a connu des myriades de
loin un royaume qui sont venus lui
rendre hommage
ainsi toutes sortes de biens précieux
sont en sa possession
cependant nous n'avons jamais accordé de
valeur aux articles moderne et nous
n'avons pas le moindre besoin de vos
produits manufacturés vous au roi devait
donc simplement agir en accord avec
notre souhait en renforçant votre
loyauté et votre éternelle obéissance ce
afin d'assurer à votre pays
la jouissance des bienfaits de la paix
sept ans plus tard une longue bourré
mais aucun traité n'avait encore été
signé
la demande en produits chinois pour
solène soit et ne cessait d'augmenter
mais les anglais hésité à proposer des
pièces d'argent les change de ces
marchandises
finalement ils trouvèrent une monnaie d
échange que les chinois ne devait pas
refuser de l'opium
importé des indes d'abord quelques
coffres puis quelques milliers quand les
autorités chinoises essayèrent de mettre
un terme au commerce de l'opium
les anglais envoient hier leur
canonnière
[Musique]
après quelques vingt ans de tours nantes
le traité de saint jean en 1858 non
seulement autorisé l'importation d'opium
mais mais également tous les ports de
chine et le commerce qui s'y pratique
est sous contrôle occidental après la
guerre l'opium inonda tout le pays et
ses empereurs ne put rien faire pour
l'empêcher la colère du dragon n'était
plus qu'une pâle imitation de ce qu'elle
avait pu être jadis la seule réponse du
monarque fut de s'isoler dans une
retraite encore plus marqués derrière
les murs de la cité interdite
il prétendait que rien n'avait changé la
célèbre impératrice douairière cixi
personnifia ce retranchement
cette auto l'absence de rapport avec la
réalité
en 1880 la cité interdite lui
appartenait à 16 ans elle avait été une
des nombreuses concubine de l'empereur
la mort de l'empereur sushi avait
organisé un coup d'état y installer son
fils âgé de six ans sur le trône
la manoeuvre était cynique mais ne
manquait pas d'audace en grandissant
toudji afficha un total d intérêt pour
le gouvernement préférant s'occuper de
lui plutôt que des affaires de l'état
mais ce simulacre de règne continuera
les courtisans venait ici dans la salle
de la culture spirituelle assister aux
audiences de l'empereur adolescents
dans cette grande salle tanghe j trônait
dans son immense fauteuil
c'est à lui que la cour venait présenter
ces requêtes tout en sachant
pertinemment que le vrai pouvoir était
littéralement derrière le trône
dissimulés derrière les rideaux de soie
c'est l'impératrice douairière qui
gouvernent l empire
j'ai souvent pensé que j'étais la forme
la plus intelligente qui ait jamais vécu
et que les autres nous pouvait se
comparer à moi j'ai entendu parler de la
reine victoria
mais saviez bien moins intéressante que
la mienne
rendez vous compte 400 millions de
personnes dépendent de moi cette
fanfaronnade étaient vides de sens
en fait le pouvoir de l'empiré était de
plus en plus isolé décadent quand le
jeune empereur morue de la variole très
vite l'impératrice douairière organise à
la mort de sa jeune épouse enceinte puis
elle plaça son neveu un autre enfant sur
le trône du dragon derrière son rideau
de soi sushi continue à tirer les
ficelles
son pouvoir n'était qu'illusoire
contrôler la cité interdite ne
signifiait plus gouverner la chine à
l'époque de sushis la vie à la cour
était celle qui avait toujours connu la
cité interdite ne sont plus opéra était
toujours donné par les eunuques était
toujours apprécié des courtisans mais
cette trop grande fidélité aux coutumes
ancestrales ne servait qu'à masquer les
problèmes de lempire des problèmes
auxquels sushi refusait de faire face
en cette fin de 19e siècle des émeutes
ont éclaté aux quatre coins du vaste
empire mais il ne s'agissait pas
seulement de nouvelles émeutes paysanne
c'était le début de la révolte des
boxers
c'est ainsi qu'on nommait les paysans
affamés qui voulait débarrasser leur
pays des barbares occidentaux ces
émeutes eux furent extrêmement violente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des troupes venues d'europe débarquèrent
bientôt en force et les représailles
furent sanglante
les combats à tenir beijing et paniquée
la famille impériale déserta le palais
des soldats occidentaux en franchir les
portes et pour la première fois des
étrangers pénétrèrent dans la grande
salle du trône sans y avoir été invité
et illizi demeurèrent
[Musique]
sushi revint honteuse et devint
locataire de son propre palais
après des années à tirer les ficelles
elle devenait la marionnette
elle conservait sa place par la grâce
des barbares
[Musique]
après sa mort le dernier empereur monta
sur le trône à l'âge de trois ans il
s'appelait pouilly quand ils m'ont
emmené dans la grande salle de
l'harmonie suprême et qui m'ont mis sur
cette immense trône je n'ai pas pu le
supporter ils m'ont dit de ne pas
gigoter mais je me suis débattue et j'ai
crié je n'aime pas cet endroit je veux
rentrer chez moi
alors que les officiels venait
s'agenouiller devant moi mais crise
faisait de plus en plus perçant mon père
essaya de me calmer en me disant ne
pleure pas ne pleure pas ce sera bientôt
fini
ce sera bientôt fini
trois ans plus tard un soulèvement
populaire balaya toute la chine et l'
empire qui devait être éternelle
s'effondra le 12 février
l'empereur le dernier empereur abdiqua
le nouveau gouvernement républicain
autorise à pouilly et ses serviteurs à
demeurer dans la cité jusqu'en 1924 en
1925 le fils du ciel fut évincé et tout
comme la chine sa vie entra dans une
phase de grand bouleversement disparu à
jamais les 1000 tunique jaune
[Musique]
en 1949 après l'instauration de la
république populaire en chine
le dernier empereur retourna chez lui et
pendant dix ans reçu une nouvelle
éducation
[Musique]
il finit ses jours comme jardinier à
beijing
les cendres de pouilly le dernier
empereur repose au cimetière de
babaoshan où sont enterrés les héros de
la révolution chinoise
rien ici n'évoque le drame qui a été sa
vie ou la gloire de la chine impériale
on ne pourra jamais en dire autant des
tombeaux des autres empereur vivant
comme mort il demeure dans la
magnificence
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les portes de la cité
interdite sont ouvertes et le simple
mortel à access et lui autrefois
interdite la grande salle où le coeur et
nourrit le palais de l'excellence divine
la porte de la paix céleste
ce sont les vestiges terrestre d'une
culture fondée sur les idées des idées
dont l'expression éternelle se fait par
le biais de l' architecture la subtilité
de l'art est une société profondément
concerné par les sciences et le langage
ce sont des vestiges hanté hanté par les
fantômes du passé mais aussi par le
spectre d'un paradis perdu
ces briques ses murs ses vies sont
toujours là ils vivent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]